five four three two one welcome to the
revs in here welcome to [ __ ] welcome to
the batagor belly I'm your captain Bob
Bob Lee the magnificent the translucent
the forever one yes
i'ma forever one we got [ __ ] white you
got [ __ ] why does here that's him that's
new yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] white all right
you're a [ __ ] remember that okay
we got his cousins [ __ ] white jr. this
one's my favorite one this one right
here is better than this one
new and improved right here Bryce you
got flat what's that yes right we got my
girlfriend kalila the princess evolved
Lotus Wow
we got me Bob Captain Bob now listen um
we've had so many guests on the show
we've had um maybe maybe a guest we've
had on the show Modern Family's Eric
Stonestreet we did it yeah was he on
time I think he was alive minutes early
yeah it was five minutes early correct
yeah yeah we've had some
african-americans the director get out
yeah he was on time correct ten minutes
early great now the biggest yeah yeah
yeah
now on this next guy coming he's here
already but um I did a college gig
without you come where the college yeah
yeah yeah I drove crazy rented a car
yeah yeah and that was a weird gig but
we had fun we had a meal afterwards I
pizza or something
afterwards no that was a different yes
that was they wrote me a letter saying
no they wrote a article up do you read
that article yeah where I was
yeah they're like that wasn't good right
they know basically they just were like
furious furious about me your material
because it was too crude to this to that
ego college kids yeah yeah yeah yeah I
got that I remember those
I read and I was really bummed about it
um this next guy also was a writer on us
and now he he was on a billboard a
couple a month ago
what was that billboard by the story was
your face uh-huh right it was some
sci-fi that sci-fi show yeah dream Corp
LLC dream Corp Elysee what channel was
it was that it's an Adult Swim Adult
Swim yeah and you were that was a really
good thing for you just in terms of
looking at that I was like and the
busiest street on Sunset your [ __ ]
big fan ever been on a billboard before
I did feel weird I am now one time
I for animal practice yeah and I'm on a
show now but they who don't use me for
the arm it's a funny one [ __ ] white huh
the day I see you want a pill talking
billboard is the day I die friend okay
it's the day I die and I'm gonna say
this right you're gonna buy a tiger
belly billboard are you really there was
a GoFundMe and started on behalf of your
desire I really want to be on a
billboard bad like but my own you know
the way I want to dress we talk about
the issues in the world the one that's
at the forefront of my mind is getting
you on a billable yeah thank you
if we need to go fund me for anything
right it's my press for about yet you
have cheeks like a chipmunk right you
have you know I said pretty bunch hair
mmm-hmm you know you're um a very funny
young man and you called me the other
day because um you're promoting
something I'm glad you did the research
you sent me you [ __ ] texted me
actually emailed you uniting get the
email but you texted me a photo of a new
movie that you're in yeah it looks great
it's very good yeah and what is the
movie called it's called the unicorn
that's right the unicorn yeah right
that's the the horse with the thing in
the head I was just in your bathroom you
have a drawing of a tattoo right I do I
love them yeah I really love unicorns
it's all about unicorns no but there's
really no unicorn on the poster low
I don't know how closely you looked at
the poster definitely is a unit you yeah
you may have missed it because it's neon
pink and it everybody on the poster
right yeah all I saw was six white heads
of people actors okay four five no no
I'm not being that's what I saw I
noticed I am no Mexican oh that's what
you are yeah that's right that's alright
that's a you saw five white guy yeah
yeah yeah so then so this move when does
it come out it came out this weekend
it's done when did this go up tomorrow
night okay tomorrow is perfect cuz now
it's on it now it's on iTunes and Amazon
oh it is yeah Tuesday so we could watch
it immediately you can watch it right
now right yeah you know quote what is it
about it's about me and Lauren lapkus is
my fiancee she's very very funny and we
are kind of bored and boring people and
we spend one night in Palm Springs we
kind of find out that her parents who
are very much in love me have threesomes
oh yeah and so we're like [ __ ] should we
be doing that
rockhard in the room right have you been
in threesome I've never been in a
threesome
you've never know who raise your hand
anyone the room that's been in threesome
price you were in a threesome who's the
person George clearly jewelry that is
George wait husbands and they are
cousins yeah of course George has his
cousin working on this yeah yeah so you
um you were in a threesome with what was
it two dudes and one girl I can see that
look at the way he's good my threesome
has been with two guys every time every
time too huh yeah
three got no no I don't know I did a
fivesome with three guys and two girls
uh-huh
oh yeah it's not funny it's not funny at
all I could tell you that story and then
I did a threesome with a guy named
Michael Burton and another comedian a
female comedian and I forgot her I know
her name but I'm not gonna say it
because it's a little you forgot it
you forgot it but that was um because
it's my ex-girlfriend
you mean Jade I do mean Jade yeah yeah
no no it wasn't Jade what happened
between you two
oh god this is like minute two
[Music]